[Music]
carter rubin took the stage during the
voices live semifinals on monday
and had gwen stefani moved to tears
i'm so honored that you picked me and
i'm crying and i'm so happy
and i'm just i love this freaking show
the 15 year old crooner performed a
jaw-dropping cover of rainbow connection
from the muppets movie
and gwen well she revealed the singer
had some big
fans in her family blake's mom literally
keeps texting me like
i hope your boy goes through i sing that
song to my kids
all millions of my children that i have
my boys
and if that wasn't sweet enough carter
dedicated the song to his older brother
jack
who has autism
carter's cover brought the coaches to
tears specifically
gwen broke down in her chair before
giving the teen a standing ovation
that was flawless perfect that was
god like answering my prayers like that
was
so beautiful i'm so happy for you you're
so gifted you're so
intuitive your heart is full of music
i'm so honored that you picked me and
i'm crying and i'm so happy
and i love this freaking show
congratulations yeah thank you
carter is the youngest contestant
currently on the show
last week he wowed the coaches with a
cover of mariah carey's hero
yeah that left gwen teary-eyed too i'm
just gonna wipe the tears because i'm
just so
honored to get to know you
you're so talented he just turned 15. he
was 14 like
a second ago and it's so fun to watch
you shine
and and be able to know that you're good
at that like
not only good you're like mind-blowingly
good
and to be able to be here too this for
america to see i'm
i have tears in my eyes i'm so proud
thanks for choosing me thank you
you're so inspiring but carter wasn't
the only one to get a standing o
on monday night
[Music]
gwen gave us major holla back girl vibes
while debuting her new song
let me reintroduce myself
[Music]
and blake he loved it i don't want to
remember
what i was like before gwen actually if
that answers your question
the country star also praised team gwen
contestant ben allen
who took a risky move on monday night
singing a classic blake shelton hit host
carson daly had jokes i finally liked
that song
excellent job but blake well
he was here for it i'm jealous because
you
slay that song and you sing it to
my fiance but i'm
also kind of wanted to be you just then
like literally man that was
i'm glad i record this show because i'm
gonna go back and watch it as for gwen
she found the whole thing pretty ironic
well i think it's funny that i'm gonna
win the voice um
with you doing blake's song it's just
like
america's gonna be all over that
you